su cirujano puede realizar la lisis
laparoscópica de adherencias oa de
tziolis es lavar hosco pica para
extirpar el tejido cicatricial de los
órganos de su abdomen
usualmente las superficies de sus
órganos abdominales son resbaladizas y
se mueven con facilidad una sobre otra a
medida que realiza sus actividades
diarias si usted tiene bandas de tejido
cicatricial en su abdomen llamadas
adherencias sus órganos abdominales se
pegarán uno a otro oa la pared abdominal
estas adherencias pueden producir una
obstrucción intestinal al estrechar sus
intestinos o torcer los o sacarlos fuera
del lugar
bloqueando de manera parcial o total a
los alimentos oa las heces que se mueven
a través de ellos si usted es mujer las
adherencias pueden causar infertilidad
al torcer o sacar las trompas de falopio
fuera del lugar
bloqueando por completo o de forma
parcial el camino de los óvulos
fecundados hasta el útero lugar en donde
el bebé puede crecer y desarrollarse la
causa más común de adherencias
abdominales es la cirugía abdominal
otras causas pueden ser las infecciones
abdominales tales como la peritonitis
las afecciones inflamatorias como
apendicitis trauma abdominal
o radiación
antes del procedimiento se le
administrara anestesia general que lo
dormirá
su cirujano le inyectará gas dentro de
su abdomen para ampliar la cavidad
abdominal lo que facilitará ver las
estructuras internas luego su cirujano
realizará una pequeña incisión para
tener acceso al interior de su abdomen
él o ella insertará un laparoscopio que
contiene una linterna una cámara y un
dispositivo de aumento
el laparoscopio proyectará imágenes en
la pantalla de tv para guiar el trabajo
de su cirujano después de examinar la
cavidad abdominal su cirujano realizará
tres o cuatro incisiones pequeñas en su
abdomen a través de las cuales pasarán
los instrumentos quirúrgicos con la
ayuda de estos instrumentos su cirujano
cortará las adherencias para liberar los
órganos entre sí
una vez que se divide en todas las
adherencias su cirujano quitará los
instrumentos laparoscópicos y cerrará
las incisiones con puntos
después de su procedimiento se le dará
seguimiento en la sala de recuperación
usted podría ir a casa el mismo día o
quedarse en el hospital hasta por tres
días para ayudar a su recuperación
mantenga la zona de la incisión limpia y
seca tome los medicamentos para el dolor
como indique su doctor
evite levantar objetos pesados y no tome
bebidas gaseosas por 2 días